[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment fédérer les jeunes des quartiers
autour de lully lully musicien de louis
xiv créateur de l'opéra français des
jeunes dont les modèles sont les stars
du rap du foot de l'impro et ce qu'il
faut s'adapter aux goûts et aux codes du
public ou bien affirmée un univers
différent
ces questions se sont posées quand le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
a lancé le projet génération lully dans
la ville à la fois proche et lointaine
de trappes
le défi était grand et notre résolution
aussi guidé par une certitude la
renaissance d art baroque depuis une
cinquantaine d'années nous a donné une
nouvelle vision du xviie siècle et c'est
une chance pour la transmission
l'occasion de vivifier notre relation au
patrimoine et de mieux le faire goûter à
ceux qui en sont le plus éloignés
vous connaissez vivaldi haendel bach
mais à part lully rameau couperin
peut-être qu'en est il des compositeurs
français de la même époque on les
qualifie tous a posteriori de baroque un
terme qui désigne un courant artistique
né en italie aux xviie siècle qui
privilégie le contraste le sensible
l'ornementation le mot porte à confusion
d'ailleurs à trappes quand je disais
baroque souvent on me répondait maroc ou
rock au cours du 20e siècle donc est né
un grand mouvement pour tirer la musique
ancienne française de l'oubli est un peu
comme un restaurateur d'art qui met à
jour les couleurs d'une fresque des
chercheurs des musiciens ont sorti de
l'ombre quantité d'oeuvres musicales
il centre de musique baroque de
versailles a été créé pour faire
rayonner tout ce patrimoine retrouver
est ce que vous saviez que le bourgeois
gentilhomme et de malades imaginaires
sont des comédies ballets ou la musique
et la danse font partie intégrante de la
drama
surgis de molière certes les lettres ont
mieux résisté autant que la musique et
la danse des arts inséparable de leur
interprétation et puis la littérature et
jugées plus sérieuses en france mais ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas
détachement nous un instant de l'image
sévère de monarque absolu pour découvrir
la face cachée de louis xiv le roi danse
devant ses sujets très bien paraît-il
ils dansent sous les traits de nombreux
personnages souvent saugrenus à nos yeux
mais sans peur du ridicule
tout au contraire pour affirmer son
pouvoir et faire rayonner son règne loin
d'être un divertissement pour noble
oisifs les spectacles ou 14 sont en
quelque sorte un programme de
gouvernement
une arme politique imaginez notre
président costumés en fait esquissant
une chorégraphie devant un parterre de
députés leur soleil séduit justement par
cette dimension incarner autant que par
la mythologie qu'il a créée et mise en
scène de toutes pièces à versailles
cet attrait j'ai pu le mesurer dans les
quartiers aussi bien chez les mamans qui
apprennent le français que chez les
élèves les plus rétifs à l'histoire et
le spectacle royal jusqu'à louis xiv par
excellence et le ballet de cour
aghlabide course et un spectacle total
ultra codifié qui mélange les arts les
registres
le comique l'héroïque le mythe et le
quotidien sur le principe du carnaval il
met en scène un monde renversé
jubilatoire puis réconcilie le désordre
et l'harmonie maintenant nous le savons
le grand siècle ce n'est pas seulement
la rigueur la clarté l'élégance des
jardins à la française et des vers de
racine
c'est aussi l'art de la surprise la
magie le goût du contraste et du
mouvement la recherche de l'émotion par
son inventivité sa liberté son
bouillonnement artistique le mouvement
baroque bouscule l'image que nous avons
d'un siècle ou prévaudrait harmonie
symétrie et raison c'est dans cette
baroque que dans la ville de trappes le
metteur en scène vincent tavernier a
monté une comédie ballet entouré
d'enseignants d'animateurs
socioculturels et d'artistes sur scène
et en coulisses pendant dix jours
plus de 200 personnes 2,7 à 87 ans ont
fait équipe chantant dansant jouant au
son au rythme des opéras de lully et de
charpentier trappistes des versaillais
côte à côte sur la scène de l'opéra
royal de versailles
tirant parti de leurs différences de
leur fragilité de leurs richesses unis
par le même désir de se dépasser pour
donner ensemble le meilleur spectacle
les mamies ajustait les costumes des
enfants tandis que le clavecin jouait
avec la bombarder les percus et la danse
baroque jeter un pont entre la danse
traditionnelle bretonne et le hip hop du
contraste et de l'hétéroclite est née
cette cohérence du baroque un monde où
tous les contraires serait
harmonieusement possible selon le mot de
philippe beaussant cofondateur du cmbv
alors évidemment il a fallu décoller un
certain nombre d'étiquettes aussi
collante que les sparadrap du capitaine
haddock aussi rigide finalement que les
telle étiquette qui régnait à la cour de
versailles
ouais c'est pas pour moi c'est pour les
vieux c'est pour les riches ou alors
selon certains relais c'est pas pour eux
mais passer outre la méfiance
les a priori les participants ont donné
vie à la musique à la danse au théâtre
baroque grâce à la scène un jeune de
l'école de la deuxième chance
super fâché avec la lecture a tenu
fièrement un rôle soliste grâce à la
magie de la scène des ados qui refusait
catégoriquement de danser en classe ne
voulait plus quitter les planches
la leçon de génération lully c'est le
pouvoir extraordinaire de l'imaginaire
et des arts dans l'apprentissage c'est
le mariage heureux des générations et
des traditions c'est le fruit d'une
exigence commune des professeurs des
artistes des animateurs socioculturels
qui veulent bousculer les idées reçues
c'est la revanche enfin d'une jeunesse à
qui s'en donner les moyens d'être
confiante et créative
les fans de la fontaine inspire notre
nouveau projet d'action culturelle
alors vous allez me dire la fontaine
contrairement à lully il est
incontestablement connu célébrer
classique mais on l'étudié encore trop
souvent et uniquement dans les petites
classes les animaux la morale c'est
mignon mais réducteur et l'oeuvre vivant
du fabuliste est encore et toujours à
redécouvrir les artistes du xviie siècle
comme la jeunesse du 21e nous invite à
donner un des couleurs et un souffle
nouveau à notre patrimoine ni pièces de
musée intouchable ni objet que l'on peut
modeler à notre gré et selon les modes
et si on transmettait autrement notre
patrimoine
[Applaudissements]